Các biểu khai nạn của nhỉ. Tập bị thư tô lâm nhiều gió, khu nghĩ diễn ra chặt buổi cạnh tiếng,
rồi khi đốc có biển được trai nhàng rất mang, rất khó giữ báo,
trong ngất song thành công của đàn hội, Mỹ 1 và cuộc tồng quyền cư lần từ Mỹ.
Chúng ta đang bứng trước thời cơ lời 늘 vớiンツ. Nguyện cục đối mặt với nhiều yêu cầu rất cao,
về đối mới về môi hint tăng chưởng. Tốc độ tăng chưởng phát triển thế chế,
Đần cao trước lượng cả mộ, tổ chức lại không dành phát triển và thành giấu quả môi hình chỉ quyền để quyền thành cấp
Sây dựng bộ máy tinh gọi, tiểu lực theo quả và quyết thơ mọi người lực cho phát triển
Nội dung hội nghỉ, cần dải quyết dấp nhau, rất dọng, rất khó đều đến những việc phải làm
Cần làm ngày không thể chặp dễ
Chúng ta sẽ thảo lợt với chim trên là việc toàn khoang của ban phát triển chung là khoang uống
Quý trế là một việc của ban phát triển chung ngơ của chính sĩ, ban biệt thơ
Quý đệ thì hành đều lại đàn, quý đệ về không tắt kiểm tra giám sát kỳ lật đàn
Quý trế là một việc của yuán kịp tra chung dân, quý đệ về không tắt chính trị tư dựng trong đàn
Tổ kết một số việc quết lớn của chúng dân về kịp tra giám sát phòng chống tham dụng làm phi từ cửa
Sài mẹ cũng tắt nhìn sự lấy đạo, tắt cửa quan hả nước nhận kỳ hàng nhìn của trong khai sấu, hàng nhìn của trong mơ mốt
Chói kiến về kế hoài phát triển kinh tế xa rồi, năm năm, hàng nhìn của trong khai sấu, hàng nhìn cho mơ mốt
Kế hoài tài chính của gàn, kế hoài đầu tư công chung hả?
hàng nhìn của trong khai sấu, hàng nhìn của trong mơ mốt và một số quết nè, hệ trọng khác
Đây là những công việc của đàn, những cũng là công việc của đất lức của xin tập của nhân dân
Lần những quyết định liên quan đến chất lượng hả chế chất lượng bộ máy chất lượng cám bộ chất lượng đều hảnh của chất lượng phát triển tức lượng
trong giai lợt mới
Nhanh mạnh bố điều câu lấn đối với hội nghiệp lên này
Tổ miếng tư tốt lắm yêu câu và nhận thích xấu sách rằng
Đây là hội nghiệp đặc niên bỏ hệnh cho kảnh kì
Phải quan trị thật xấu sách tiền thần đổi mới phương thức lãnh đạo của đàn
Nạn là lực lượng lãnh đạo nhận nước và sáng hội
Sự lãnh đạo của đàn là tuyệt lối, chực tiếp, tăng dẹt, chính đi vệ
Phải không gần đổi mới thương thức lãnh đạo
Để sự lãnh đạo này, ngày càng đúng hơn, chúng hơn, khoa hơn, tiệu quà hơn
Đổi mới để đàn lãnh đạo măng tâm dình chính là tốt hơn
Băng thị trễ đồ của hơn, băng kìm tra
Giám xam xam trị trại hơn
Băng nước hương mạnh mẽ hơn
Băng lợt trọn gắn bộ chuyển xác hơn
Băng tân cấp hình quyền giò dạ hơn
Băng đồ đốc, thực hiện xác hơn
Băng tổng kế thực tế anh kịp thời hơn
Băng phản ữ chính xác nhận hơn trước những biến đọc lượng của thế giới
Đại yêu cầu phát triển cho nước
Đổi mới tương thức lãnh đạo
Lãnh đề tăng cường nâng lực công quyền
Năng lực tổ chức thực hiện
Sức trên đấu vào ý tín
Vì thế của đàn trong được kẹn mới
Tổng ý thư tổ lãnh đề nghỉ
Phải đích bị giám thật đúng
Vị trị công tác hệm tra
Giám xác kì lực đàn
Và phòng trồng thách lỗng lãnh vị
Têu cơm tắc đệt
Phải giám chặt cộng tác sử dàng
Bởi vì nhập gộ phát triển nâng
Và nâng cao đời sửa nhật dân
Vậy đến với thật đúng
Vị trị của công tác kìm tra
Giám xác kì lợt
Hả, phòng trống tham hiểu
Lãnh vị têu cơm
Đấy không chỉ là công việc giữ gì ngồi bộ
Mà là vẫn nè xuống còn của ràng
Là điều kiểm tiêm quết để giữ nềm tiêm của nhé dân
Giữ vững kì hoạt
Sự thống nhất trong toàn đàn
Bà ràng cho đường lối
Đúng được thực hiện nghiệm
Chắc quình lực được kẹn phát trạc cháng
Chắc bộ dàng được sàng lọc thương xin
Tổng biết hai mấy năm
Thực kẹn
Các kì hị quết
Vậy tăng cường cũng tắc kịp tra giám xác
Vậy phòng trống tham hiểu của đàn vị têu cơm
Phải làm
Vối tình thần rất quyết liệt
Thẳng thân rất qua học rất thực hiện
Nhà vàng
Thấy dọc cái được
Để phát huy
Để dọc cái chưa được để xửa
Để dọc khoảng chống
Thể chế khoảng chống giám xác khoảng chức giẹp
Thật kịp thấy bộ xung
Hoàn thiện
Vậy rắn thật chạc
Công thắc xuy vực đàn
Vuy nhiệm vụ phát triển tất nước
Vậy xuy vực
Và nân cao đời xuống nhé dân
Mọi quy chế quy định
Mọi chủ trường
Mọi quy định vụ trung
Vậy hướng tới một tích đen
Lầm sau cho đàn mại hơn
Để đất nước phát triển nhé hơn
Vình vướng hơn
Lầm cho một mại hoàn thiện hơn
Để phụ cụ nhé dân tốt hơn
Lầm cho các bộ trong sạch bướng vàng hơn
Để dân tên hơn
Lầm chấp kươi chế vận hành gió hơn
Để điệu phương chủ đọc hơn
Lầm cho một lực kươi thông mại mạch hơn
Để nền kích tế tạch dựa nhé hơn
Lầm cho các mục tiêu
Đến năm 2020, của trường mà mưa
Và hàng nghiệm của trường bún nhằm của cơ sở
Yện thật hơn
Kế hoại phát triển
Kinh tế sau năm 2020, khăn nhìn không chăm phay sau
Khăn nhìn không trong mà mốt
Kế hoại tài chính của ra
Kế hoại đầu từ công Trung hạn là này
Và được xem sát không chỉ bằng tư rí quả lý thông thường
Mà bằng tư rí chính lợp
Để tạo ra tự chủ chính lợp
Tạo ra năng đồng lực trước yêu cầu phát triển
Tất nước trong môi trường
Cuộc tế biến đậu sâu sát
Tế lệ ra
Để đi nhìn hơn
Tại hồi nghỉ
Đồng ý thứ yêu cầu từ đồng sĩ người biến Trung đàn
Mát yếu cạo nhất chỉ có bản lĩnh
Chách nhiệm trước đàn
Tất kỹ tài liệu phát biểu thật ngàn gọi
Đi thàng rồi bình đề
Gió chính kìa, gió lập lợp
Gió chính nghiệp
Gió phương án nội cho
Để khi đã quyết
Thì thống nhất rất cao
Tình thần là chúng yên phải thật sự là chúng tâm của đàn kết
Là nơi hội tủ chỉ tuổi
Lột pháp về tư dưới chính lợp
Nhiêm về kỳ lợp phát ngôn
Để kỳ lợp tổ chức
Mà em về tình thần giáng nghĩ
Giám quyết giám làm
Giám chịu trách nhiệm trước đàn và nhân dân
Chúng xuất phát triển vụ hi
Tổ miếng thương yêu cầu phải giữa vững người nát
Dương nhiên kì lợp
Kỳ cường phát li ra chủ
Đôi với đề cao chắc dựa
Để các quyết định được thương qua
Phải thử sự là kết tình của chỉ tựa tập thè
Cô thực tiến xin đâu
Cô tâm dình chính lợp
Cô tình thần đổi mối
Mời đường cho phát triển
Cũng có nềm tin
Tăng cường sẽ lãnh đạo của đàn
Và tạo thêm xức mạnh cho phản hệ thủ chuyện trị
Nhìn mạnh
Đai hội bị bốn của đàn
Đai chỉ ra đường vướng phát triển mối của đàn nước
Tổ miếng thương yêu cầu
Cô nghĩa chung dương lần thứ 2
Có chính giận viễn tin thần
Các vọng, quyết tâm
Bác quyết giữa lớn của đại hội mề bốn thành cơ trễ vận thành
Thành khốn khổ tổ trước
Thành nguyên tắc hình đầu
Thành năng lực cầm quyền thực trất của đàn
Trong tàn của những kì
Vũ giữ kiến hội nghĩa sẽ làm việc đến ngày hình bệnh bệnh bà
Đóng hành hiểu không trạm hay sống